大家好,
我是Jim,
這裡是AI Notebook,
這裡是簡史系列,
每一集用一條線,
把一段歷史從頭走一遍,
這一集我們走晶片的80年,
你現在把手機拿起來,
它比一本筆記本還輕,
裡面最重要的那片晶片比你的指甲還小,
上面卻有上百億個開關,
80年前,
一臺只會做計算的電腦要佔滿一整個房間,
這一集只問一個問題,
一片這麼小的戲是怎麼改變我們每天的生活的,
我先把答案放在前面,
同一件事,
發生了一次又一次,
開關變得更小,
更便宜,
多到每個人都用得起,
就有一件新的東西走進普通人的生活,
收音機 計算機 個人電腦 網絡 手機
還有今天的人工智慧
而每往前一步
需要一起動手的人和國家也越來越多
這條線分三步走
先看一整個房間
怎麼變成一片晶片
再看書桌上的電腦
怎麼走進每個人的口袋
最後看今天這片晶片背後
跨越很多國家的供應鏈
中間有一頓早餐
吃在臺北車站附近的一間豆漿店
我們留到後面
故事要從1940年代的一臺電腦開始
1940年代
美國賓州大學蓋了一臺電腦叫INIAC
他佔滿了一整個房間
裡面裝了將近18000只Vacuum Tube
中文叫真空管
真空管長得像一顆小燈泡
在這裡你可以先把它想成一個電子開關
讓電流通過
或者不讓電流通過
你家牆上的電燈開關
往上搬
燈就亮
往下搬
燈就暗
真空管做的是類似的事
只是他不用手搬
是用電來搬
電腦說穿了就是一大堆這樣的開關
可是這種開關有三個麻煩
太大
太燙
而且容易壞
美國的電腦歷史博物館記錄
FINAC
大約每一兩天
就要燒掉一隻真空管
工程師得在一萬多隻裡面
把壞的那一只找出來換掉
你想要更厲害的電腦
就得放更多開關
可是開關越多
壞的越頻繁
房間也越熱
所以最早的問題是
開關能不能小一點
冷一點
而且不要那麼容易壞
那一堆開關
為什麼可以算數
一個開關有兩種狀態
開著我們叫它一
關著我們叫它零
只有一個開關能表達的東西很少
可是你把八個開關排成一排
開開關關的組合
就足夠代表一個英文字母
真正關鍵的是用電搬的開關
可以讓一個開關的結果
去搬下一個開關
這樣接起來就能做出這種規則
兩個開關都開著
下一個才開
用很多這種小規則疊起來
就能做加法做比較
也能把結果記住
所以一臺電腦能做多少事
很大一部分取決於
它有多少開關
這些開關切換的多快
看一個時代的晶片
很重要的一個指標
就是上面擺了多少開關
ENIAC的開關
是一隻一隻的真空管
每一隻都像燈泡那麼大
要讓電腦更強
一條關鍵的路
是把開關做小
1947年的冬天
一間實驗室
做出了一種新的開關
這一間實驗室
是美國電報公司
AT&T的Bell Labs
中文叫貝爾實驗室
1947年12月
兩位物理學家
John Badin
和Walter Breton
在一小塊叫Germanium
中文叫褶的材料上
壓了兩個
靠得很近的金色接點
他們發現在其中一個接點
送進一點點電流
另一邊流過的電流
就會跟著被放大
或者被關掉
這個東西叫Transistor
中文叫電晶體
它做的是
就是我們說的那個開關
用一個小小的電
去搬一個比較大的電
跟真空管不一樣
它不需要加熱燈絲
褶這種材料
叫Semiconductor
中文叫半導體
它導電的本事
介於銅線這種導體
和玻璃這種絕緣體之間
而且可以被控制
這真是做開關需要的性質
那個月的23日
他們把這個東西展示給
實驗室的主管看
開關這件事
從這一天起
不再需要一顆燈泡
9年後
Bardin
Bretain
還有帶領他們團隊的
William Shockley一起拿到了諾貝爾物理學獎
電晶體發明以後
最先把它帶進普通人家裡的
不是電腦是收音機
1954年11月
美國的德州儀器公司Texas Instruments
宣佈了第一臺商用的電晶體收音機
叫Regency TRE
它裡面只有四顆電晶體
以前的收音機
是放在客廳的一個木頭箱子
要插電
然後等真空管熱起來
這一臺可以放進外套口袋
用電池就能聽
它在當時不便宜
可是賣得很好
美國的電腦歷史博物館說
很多人是從這臺收音機
第一次聽到電晶體這個詞
你可以想象那個畫面
一個年輕人走在街上
口袋裡放著收音機
耳機裡是自己想聽的歌
開關變小了
音樂就可以隨身帶著走
這是電晶體第一次
這麼直接的走進普通人的生活
可是這時候的電晶體
還是一顆一顆的
而且用的材料有一個怕熱的毛病
收音機裡的電晶體用的是褶
褶有一個問題
怕熱
電腦歷史博物館的整理是
褶做的電晶體
溫度一高就不太可靠
而且關著的時候還會露出不少電流
一個關不緊的開關
對電腦來說是很麻煩的事
Silicon 中文叫矽
在這兩件事上都好得多
它能在熱得多的地方工作
關起來也比較緊
矽還有一個更大的好處
砂紙的主要成分就是矽跟氧
而矽的表面一加熱
就會長出一層很薄的玻璃
叫二氧化錫
這層玻璃可以把底下的東西保護起來
還能把電擋住
這層玻璃後來會變得非常重要
1954年
美國的德州儀器公司
Texas Instruments
做出了第一批可以賣的錫電晶體
1955年
當年帶領貝爾實驗室團隊的
William Shockley
回到加州
開了一家公司
要做用錫做的電晶體
那一代後來有了一個名字叫錫鼓
Shockley找來的年輕人很優秀
可是Shockley很難相處
電腦歷史博物館的說法是
他的管理風格多疑又尖刻
員工去找公司的出資者
希望換掉他
沒有成功
1957年9月
八個年輕人一起離開
後來大家把他們叫做Traitors 8
意思是八個叛徒
其中有兩個人
後來改變了整個產業
Robin Noyce和Golden Moore
他們透過一位年輕的投資銀行家
Arthur Rock牽線
找到Fairchild攝影器材公司出資
成立了Fairchild Semiconductor
中文叫快捷半導體
這在當時很少見
一群工程師一起離開老闆
拿別人的錢
自己開公司
後來矽谷一代一代的新公司
很多都是這樣開始的
可是新公司要做出成績
得先面對一個老問題
開關雖然變小了
把他們接起來還是一件苦工
那時候的電競體
是一顆一顆做好
再用手一根一根接起來的
你想想一臺收音機的電路板
電晶體
電阻電容
每個零件都有兩三隻腳
工人要用焊錫
把它們跟電線焊在一起
一臺電腦要幾千個
甚至幾萬個零件
就會有好幾萬個焊點
每一個焊點都可能接不好
只要一個壞了
整臺機器就可能出錯
這其實回到了ENIAC的老問題
只是換了一個樣子
以前是開關本身會壞
現在是開關之間的線會出問題
開關越多
線越多
出錯的地方也越多
還有一件事
但是線越長 電跑得越久 電腦也就越慢
所以想要更多開關
不能只是把開關做小 還得想辦法
不要再一根一根去接
當時的工程師把這件事看得很清楚
問題不在開關在接線
1958年的夏天
德州有一位剛到職的工程師
在大家都去度假的時候 一個人留在實驗室裡想這件事
這位工程師叫Jack Kilby
在德州儀器公司上班
他的想法很簡單 也很大膽
既然電晶體是用半導體做的 那電阻跟電容
能不能也用同一塊半導體做
如果所有零件都長在同一塊材料上
就不用一顆一顆做
再一顆一顆接
1958年9月
他把一片很小的折片拿給主管看
上面做出了電晶體和其他零件
接上電
儀器的螢幕上出現了一條穩定的波形
這個東西
我還叫integrated circuit
中文叫集體電路
意思是把整個電路集合在一片材料上
這也就是我們今天說的晶片
42年後
QB
因為這件事拿到諾貝爾物理學獎
得獎理由是
他在集體電路的發明上所做的貢獻
可是你如果仔細看他那片折片零件之間
還是用細細的金線在空中拉來拉去
接線的問題只解決了一半
另一半在加州的快捷半導體被補上了
細表面那層薄薄的玻璃
這時候派上了用場
快捷的物理學家Jan Horny想到
做完電晶體以後不要把這層玻璃去掉
把它留在上面當保護層
這樣一來所有東西都可以從同一面一層一層做上去
整片晶片是平的
這個方法叫planar process
中文叫平面製程
1959年Robert Noyce接著往下想
既然表面是平的
還蓋著一層玻璃
那零件之間的線
就不用在空中拉了
直接在玻璃上面鋪一層很薄的鋁
再把不要的部分去掉
留下來的鋁就變成了連線
這是整個故事最關鍵的一步
從這一刻開始
晶片不再是一顆一顆組裝出來的
而是零件跟連線在同一片繫上
一層一層一起製造出來
一百個開關跟一萬個開關
可以用同一套步驟同時做出來
接下來幾十年的晶片產業
都建立在這個做法上
平面製程做出來的機體電路
一開始很貴
最早大量買它的是
太空跟國防
美國的阿波羅登月計畫
要在太空船上放一臺電腦
幫太空人算方向跟位置
這臺電腦叫Apollo Guidance Computer
中文叫阿波羅導航電腦
它不能像ENIAC大
太空船裡面有那個空間
所以它用了機體電路
電腦歷史博物館的記錄是
每一臺導航電腦
都用了幾千顆同一種機體電路
整個計畫前後買了大約20萬顆
到1965年為止
它是全世界機體電路最大的買家
後來美國空軍的飛彈計劃又超過了它
這些大訂單也讓早期的機體電路工廠
累積了大量生產的經驗
1969年7月
太空人登上月球
那一趟路上幫他們算方向的
就是一臺用機體電路做成的電腦
一臺電腦第一次小到可以放進太空船
接下來它要小到可以放在一張書桌上
甚至一個人的手掌上
1968年
諾伊斯和莫爾離開了快捷
自己開了一家新公司
叫Intel
1971年11月
Intel推出了一片晶片
叫4004
它原本是替日本一家計算機公司
Musicom做的
要放進一臺桌上型計算機
可是它不只是一片計算機晶片
它把一臺電腦最核心
負責計算跟判斷的部分
整個放進了同一片晶片裡
這種東西叫Micro Processor
中文叫微處理器
Intel自己的說法是
這是世界上第一個
在市面上買得到的微處理器
這片晶片上
有2300個電晶體
同一段時間
計算機也開始變成
每個人都買得起的東西
電腦歷史博物館的記錄是
1971年第一款
大量銷售的手持計算機
還要200多美元
不到10年
類似的計算機
價錢只剩下原來的一個零頭
學生 會計 菜市場的老闆
都開始有自己的計算機
2300這個數字
後面我們會拿一顆今天的晶片來對照
我們先停一下
把第一部分收起來
開關從真空管變成了電晶體
材料從褶換成了細
零件之間的線
從用手焊
變成在同一片細上
跟零件一起做出來
每小一步
就有一樣東西走進生活
收音機放進了口袋
電腦上的太空船
計算機放上了桌子
記住這一句
晶片是一整片
一層一層製造出來的
那下一個問題就很自然了
線能做多細
越做越細
又能把電腦帶到哪裡
第一個認真回答
能做多細的人
是Golden Moore
1965年
他還在快捷半導體
一本電子產業的雜誌
請他寫一篇文章
預測未來十年
他把過去幾年的晶片
畫在一張圖上
發現一件很規律的事
每一片晶片上
成本最划算的零件數量
一片晶片上會有好幾萬個零件
他在文章裡還寫了一句
集體電路會帶來家用電腦
汽車的自動控制
還有可以隨身攜帶的個人通訊設備
那是1965年
你手上的手機
那時候連影子都沒有
十年後
他把速度修正成大約每兩年翻一倍
後來有一位加州理工學院的教授
Carver Mead
替這個觀察取了名字
叫Morse Law
中文叫More定律
它不是物理定律
比較像一張全產業一起追的時間表
這張時間表後來推著整個產業
走了半個世紀
要做得更細
得先講清楚
電路的圖案
是怎麼放到戲上的
晶片是做在一片
圓形的薄細片上
這片戲叫Wafer
中文叫晶圓
把圖案放上去的方法
叫Photolithography
中文叫微影
也有人叫光刻
它的做法
跟沖洗照片有點像
首先在晶圓表面
塗上一層
對光很敏感的材料
叫光組
再來
拿一塊叫光罩的板子
上面有電路的圖案
光穿過光罩
經過一組鏡頭
把圖案縮小
投影在光組上
被光照到的地方
性質會改變
用藥水一洗
就留下了圖案
如果要打個比方
光照
有點像印刷用的板
光纖墨
把同一個圖案
一次又一次轉到晶圓上
可是這個比方只對一半
美影負責的是
把圖案轉上去
真正把每一層做出來的是
後面的步驟
層級
是把一層薄薄的材料鋪上去
石刻
是把不要的部分去掉
摻雜
是把別的元素加進系裡
改變它導電的性質
這套方法最早是
是1950年代貝爾實驗室的研究人員
從電路板的製板技術借過來的
他讓工廠可以一次又一次
重複製作同一套圖案
可是一片晶片不是隻做一層
一顆現代的晶片是幾十層圖案疊起來的
有的層放電晶體
有的層放連線
一層一層往上疊
每一層都要對準下面那一層差一點點
上下兩層的線路就接不起來
一片晶圓上會同時做出很多顆晶片
問題是
只要一粒灰塵落在錯的位置
那顆晶片就壞了
所以工廠要蓋成比開刀房還乾淨的房間
叫五層室
這就帶出了晶片業最重要的一個詞
叫Yield
中文叫良率
它的意思是
一片晶圓做完以後
能用的晶片佔了多少
良率九成
跟良率五成
用的是一樣的機器
一樣的材料
能賣的晶片卻差了將近一倍
所以晶片工廠之間
在比的不只是誰的現化的最細
也是誰能在幾百道步驟裡
每一步都不出錯
臺灣後來的故事
跟良率這兩個字關係很深
那為什麼大家一定要做得更細
1974年IBM的工程師Robert Dennard和同事發表了一篇論文
他們說明電晶體縮小的時候
如果電壓跟電流也照比例一起降
每個開關就能更快
也更省電
而且同樣面積裡發出的熱不會增加
這個規律後來叫Dennard Scaling
中文叫Dennard縮放
泛神生活化就是在這些條件還成立
製造也跟得上了那幾十年裡
把電晶體做小
同一塊麵積就能放更多開關
速度跟耗電一起變好
每一個功能的成本也有機會往下降
可是好處的背後有代價
沒往下做細帶
光照要更精準
機器要更好
工廠也要更乾淨
晶片工廠在業界叫Fab
中文叫晶圓廠
產業裡有一個經驗法則
叫Rock's Law
名字來自前面牽線成立會計的
那位Arthur Rock
大意是蓋一座晶圓廠的成本
大約每四年就翻一倍
它不是精確的定律
可是方向很清楚
晶片越做越好
蓋工廠的門檻也越來越高
做得起的公司越來越少
晶片越做越便宜
電腦就從大公司的機房
走到了普通人的書桌上
1977年
Apple II開始上市
它是一臺整臺組好的電腦
有主機板
有電源
有鍵盤
有外殼
買回家插上電就能用
電腦歷史博物館的記錄是
從1977年到1993年
Apple II賣出了好幾百萬臺
1981年8月12日
IBM在紐約的一間飯店
發表了IBM PC
它用的處理器
是Intel的8088
PC這兩個字
是Personal Computer的縮寫
中文叫個人電腦
你想一下那時候的變化
以前要算賬
要打報告
要找一部大型電腦排隊等著用
現在一個會計師
一個學生
一個小店老闆
在自己的桌上就能做
這一次
晶片讓電腦
從一個機構的東西
變成一個人的東西
可是要讓每個家庭都買得起
電腦裡面的另一種晶片
也得變得很便宜
那種晶片負責寄東西
這種負責寄東西的晶片
叫DRAM
中文叫動態隨機存取記憶體
電腦正在用的資料
都暫時放在它上面
在這種晶片的競爭裡
有一段時間
走到最前面的是日本
Anderson在華盛頓的一場會議上
公佈了一份測試結果
他們拿美國跟日本供應商的
記憶體晶片來比
日本晶片的故障率
比美國的低很多
有的說法是好幾倍
甚至十倍
DRAM的結構很規律
一大片一模一樣的小格子
比的就是誰做得多
做得準
做得便宜
日本的NEC
東芝日立的這些公司
把工廠管得非常細
良率一路往上
到了1980年代後半
日本的公司拿下了
全世界大約七八成的DRAM市場
記憶體便宜了
能把良率做到最高
把成本壓到最低的人才會贏
就在各家大公司彼此競爭的時候
另一條路悄悄打開了
1980年
替摩爾定律取名的教授Covermead
跟Xerox研究中心的Lin Conway
出版了一本教科書
叫《Introduction to VLSI Systems》
這本書
教你用一套規則化電路
只要照著規則化
不用懂工廠裡每一臺機器的設計
就有機會交出去做
設計晶片的人
跟製造晶片的人
第一次可以分開
1984年前後
美國開始出現一種新的公司
只設計晶片
自己沒有工廠
這種公司叫Fabulous
意思是沒有晶圓廠的公司
可是設計要交給誰
那時候的晶圓廠
幾乎都屬於自己賣晶片的大公司
Triple E Spectrum
雜誌在一篇介紹張忠謀的文章裡寫到
小公司的晶片
只有在大公司的產線有空時才能做
大公司談條件時
還常常要求把設計一起移轉過去
產品賣得好
大公司就可能推出互相競爭的晶片
就算對方沒有這樣做
客戶也很難不擔心
把最值錢的設計交給一個同行
保密跟利益衝突
就成了每天都要想的事
世界上還缺一家只幫別人製造
自己不賣晶片產品的公司
1974年1月7日
那個冬天的早上
臺北車站附近
一間叫小星星的豆漿店樓上
坐了七個人
有經濟部長孫運璇
行政員秘書長費華
交通部長高玉樹
還有一位從美國回來的工程師
潘文淵
潘文淵當時在美國的RCA
中文叫美國無線電公司
主持一間研究室
那時候臺灣的電子業
多半是幫外國公司
組裝收音機跟電視
賺的是很薄的工錢
這頓早餐討論的是
臺灣下一步能做什麼
潘文淵的建議是
做機體電路
在座的人同意了
那年夏天
潘文淵把自己
關在圓山飯店
寫出一份
機體電路計劃的草案
孫運權當天下午就批准了
後來立法院通過了
一筆四年的預算
大約一千萬美元
以今天的眼光看
這筆錢很小
可是對當時的臺灣
這是一筆很大的投資
而且要做的
是臺灣從來沒做過的東西
計劃要做
得先找有經驗的公司來調
1976年3月
工業技術研究院
大家叫它工研院
跟美國的RCA簽了技術移轉合約
RCA答應
把一套做機體電路的技術交給臺灣
這套技術做出來的線寬是7維米
大概是一根頭髮粗細的十分之一
那在當時已經不是最先進的
美國最前面的工廠
已經做得更細了
可是對一個從零開始的地方
先學會穩穩的做
比做的最細更重要
那一年4月
第一批19個臺灣的年輕工程師
飛到美國的RCA受訓
帶隊的是楊丁元
裡面有史青泰
曾凡成
蔡明介
他們要把每一道步驟
都學會帶回臺灣
這一批人
後來很多都成了
臺灣半導體業的骨幹
曾凡成後來當上
臺積電的副董事長
蔡明介後來創辦了聯發科技
他們帶回來的
不只是一套技術
而是一種能力
知道一座晶圓廠
每一天要怎麼把它顧好
他們回來以後
工研院蓋了一座示範工廠
1977年工廠開始運轉
工研院自己的記錄寫著
營運第六個月
良率就達到了七成
良率就是一片晶圓做完
能用的晶片佔多少
一群第一次做集體電路的
臺灣工程師
半年就把這件事做得很穩
有些說法還說
這個良率比
RCA自己的工廠還高
可是工廠的記錄只寫了七成
我們就講到這裡
這件事證明的是
臺灣的工程師
能在很短的時間裡
把一條產線的製造能力建立起來
接下來政府做了兩件事
1980年
工研院把這套技術跟一部分的人
分出去成立一家公司
叫蓮花電子
大家叫它蓮電
這是臺灣第一家集體電路公司
同一年的12月
新竹科學工業園區成立
蓮電是最早搬進去的公司之一
可是蓮電在那時候
跟全世界其他晶片公司一樣
自己設計
自己製造
自己賣
那種只專心幫別人制造的公司
還沒有出現
1985年
一個人從美國來到臺灣
接下工研院院長的位置
他叫張忠謀
張忠謀在美國讀書
拿到史丹佛大學的博士
他在德州儀器公司待了25年
一路做到負責全球半導體業務的主管
後來又去一家叫General Instruments的公司當總裁
請他回臺灣的
是孫運璇
他到臺灣才幾個禮拜
當時的政務委員李國鼎就把他找去
張忠謀在電腦歷史博物館的口述訪談裡回憶
李國鼎對他說
你看起來很適合在臺灣開一家新公司
給我們一份營運計劃
張忠謀後來說過一句話
沒有李國鼎就沒有臺積電
那時候他已經50多歲
在很多人開始想退休的年紀
他要回答一個問題
臺灣能開一傢什麼樣的晶片公司
才有機會贏
張忠謀的答案來自一張很誠實的清單
他在口述訪談裡說
當時的臺灣研究開發沒有優勢
電路設計沒有優勢
銷售跟行銷也沒什麼優勢
智慧財產權幾乎也沒有
唯一可能的優勢
而且只是可能不是明擺著的
是半導體製造
你回想一下公園院那座示範工廠
半年就把良率做到七成
臺灣最有機會的地方
就是把一條產線顧好
然後他把這一點
對上前面講的那個需求
全世界越來越多人會設計晶片
卻蓋不起工廠
有工廠的
大多是自己賣晶片的大公司
那如果臺灣開一家公司
不設計也不賣自己的晶片
只幫別人製造呢
這種模式叫Pure Play Foundry
中文叫專業晶圓代工
張忠謀的自傳寫著
他花了大約兩個禮拜
把這份營運計畫寫出來
他在訪談裡還用了一個很老實的說法
你也可以叫他最不壞的那個選擇
意思是在幾個都不理想的選項裡
壞處最少的那一個
他從臺灣的限制出發
找到的是一門當時全世界還沒有人專心做的生意
1987年1月
臺灣機體電路製造公司成立
大家叫它臺積電
那一年張忠謀55歲
最大的股東是行政院開發基金
第二大的是荷蘭的菲利普
第一座工廠是跟工研院租來的
張忠謀自己說
那時候的技術比世界最前面落後了兩個半世代
外面的反應很冷淡
很多人的第一個反應是
臺灣到底在搞什麼
可是這家公司有一個承諾
它在年報裡寫著
公司本身不設計
不生產
也不銷售自由品牌的產品
確保不跟客戶直接競爭
你把這句話放回前面那個問題
就知道它有多重
一顆晶片的設計
是一家公司最值錢的東西
臺積電說的是
我只幫你製造
你的設計在我這裡
不會變成我的產品
這種承諾靠一句話不夠
要靠很多年不破例
客戶才會相信
一開始願意下單的反而是自己有工廠的大公司
像英特爾、德州儀器、摩托羅拉
張忠謀回憶、英特爾派人來看工廠
挑出了很多問題
臺積電一個一個改
信任
是這樣一張訂單一張訂單累積出來
臺積電在新竹慢慢站穩的那幾年
世界上桌上的電腦越來越多
下一件事是把他們連起來
1989年3月
在歐洲的核子研究組織Seren
一位英國的研究員Tim Berners-Lee寫了一份提案
他想讓擅在各地的研究者
可以用一種簡單的方法
互相看到彼此的文件
這個想法
後來叫World Wide Web
中文叫全球資訊網
也就是我們今天說的網頁
1990年第一個網站
在Cern的一臺電腦上跑了起來
1991年
他把這套軟體公開給外面的人
你今天點開的每一個連結
都建立在這個發明上
這一步的主角是軟體
可是還能普及到全世界
是因為接上網的每一臺電腦
每一臺伺服器
每一臺路由器裡面
都有越來越便宜的晶片
伺服器
就是放在機房裡
專門把網頁送給你的電腦
電腦從一個人的東西
變成了一群人連在一起的東西
1990年代
越來越多沒有工廠的晶片公司
把設計交給臺積電
其中一家很小的公司
叫NVIDIA
做的是處理畫面的圖形晶片
張忠謀自己講過這段故事
NVIDIA打電話到臺積電
在美國的辦公室
一直沒有人回
創辦人黃仁勳就寫了一封信給他
張忠謀多多信自己打電話過去說
我是臺積電的張忠謀
我要找黃仁勳先生
黃仁勳在2007年
電腦歷史博物館的一場活動上回憶
1997年他們見面的時候
NVIDIA只有大約100個人
隔年就開始跟臺積電合作
他還記得張忠謀對他說過
我們會為你全力以赴
這家當年的小公司
後來做出了今天訓練人工智慧
最重要的那些晶片
而那些晶片到今天還是由臺積電製造
這個故事好聽的地方
不是誰幫了誰
而是他剛好示範了那個模式
一家只會設計的小公司
不用蓋工廠
也能做出世界級的晶片
而愛越成功
臺積電的產線就越猛
NVIDIA只是其中一家
臺積電成立以後的20年
沒有工廠的晶片公司
一家一家成立
做手機晶片的
做網路晶片的
做繪圖晶片的
很多都把製造交給了新竹
這裡有一個很重要的機制
臺積電做的晶元越多
在製程上碰到的狀況也越多
沒解決一個問題
累積下來的是製程
設備跟品質管理上的改進
這些改進
可以用在後面的產品上
要注意
這裡累積的不是客戶的設計
客戶的設計仍然是客戶自己
產量越大
工程師看過的狀況越多
良率就比較有機會往上走
良率上去
每一顆好晶片的成本就往下降
交貨也更穩定
價格最後由市場決定
可是成本比較低
交貨比較穩
客戶就更願意來
客戶多了產量又更大
這個循環一旦轉起來
後面的公司要追
又得付出很大的代價
臺積電累積的是來自很多客戶
很多種產品的製造經驗
這是專業晶元代工最大的好處之一
接下來晶片要走進口袋
手機靠電池
所以晶片不只要快
還要省電
1990年11月
在英國劍橋郡的一間舊股倉裡
一家叫ARM的公司成立了
它是由ACON電腦
Apple和VLSI Technology一起出資的
ARM不自己製造晶片
它設計一種很省電的處理器架構
在授權給別的公司去用
處理器架構
就是一顆處理器聽得懂的那一套基本指令
ARM自己的說法是
今天全世界超過99%的智慧型手機
都用它的技術
2007年1月9日
Apple發表了iPhone
把手機音樂播放器
上網的工具
放進了同一隻手機裡
手機從打電話的工具
變成一臺放在口袋裡的電腦
國際電信聯盟
2024年的統計是
全世界10歲以上的人
5個人裡
有4個有自己的手機
80年前
一臺電腦佔滿一個房間
現在
它在大多數人的口袋裡
我們再停一下
把第一部分收起來
線越做越細
晶片越來越便宜
電腦走上書桌
網路把他們連起來
手機放進了口袋
可是工廠也越來越貴
做得起的人越來越少
設計跟製造分開以後
臺灣補上了專心幫別人製造的那一塊
記住這一句
晶片越便宜
走進生活的東西越多
背後的工廠卻越來越難蓋
到了這裡
一片先進的晶片
已經不是一個國家做得出來的了
可是到了2000年代
開關本身出了問題
德納德說放縮的那種好處
大約在2005年前後開始失效
電壓沒辦法照比例往下降
電晶體縮得太小
就算關起來
電還是會從底下偷偷漏過去
一個關不緊的開關
會一直漏電一直發熱
有一個重要的解法
來自一位在臺灣長大的工程師
胡正明他在加州大學博克萊分校的團隊
在1999年發表了一種新結構
叫FinFET
中文叫騎士電晶體
以前的電晶體是平的
控制開關的那一層叫雜極
只從上面壓著電流的通道
FinFET把通道立起來
像一片魚鰭
雜極從三面把它包住
開關就更容易關緊
他沒有讓疊壓噪比例下降的那段日子回來
可是他讓電晶體可以繼續往下縮
漏電也控制得住
胡正明在2001年到1004年
擔任臺積電的第一任技術長
Intel最早把這種立體電晶體用進量產的產品
臺積電在2015年開始量產
16nm的FinFET
在製程持續演進的同時
臺積電也碰上了一個很大的客戶
你口袋裡如果是iPhone
裡面那顆主晶片
是Apple自己設計的
叫A系列
早期A系列是由誰製造
用的是哪一種製程
外界的資訊主要來自第三方的晶片分析公司
他們會把手機打開來看
2014年
他們發現
iPhone 6的A8晶片
是臺積電用20nm製造的
在那之前
目前Apple的主晶片主要是三星製造的
2015年
A9晶片由三星跟臺積電兩家分著生產
從2016年的A10開始
分析顯示都有臺積電生產
一般認為
臺積電一種新的封裝技術
也就是把晶片包起來接到外面的方法
是他拿下訂單的原因之一
這件事
對整個故事的意義在於數量
每一年上億隻手機
意思是臺積電每一年
都要在最新的那一代製程上
做出非常大量的晶片
前面說的那個循環
在最新的製程上
轉得最快
電晶體越做越小
圖案就得越畫越細
眉影能畫出多細的線
受到光的波長限制
圖案很難比光的波長細太多
於是下一步
換了一種光叫EUV
中文叫極紫外光
它的波長
只有原本主流那種光的十幾分之一
這種光很難產生
荷蘭的SML公司這樣描述的
一顆一顆很小的錫滴
從噴嘴裡射出來
先被一道雷射打扁
再被一道更強的雷射打成電漿
電漿發出的
就是極紫外光
這個過程
每秒要重複五萬次
這種光也很難控制
它會被一般的鏡片吸收掉
所以機器裡的鏡頭
換成了一面一面多層的反射鏡
連光照都改成會反射的
那些反射鏡
由德國的蔡司獨家供應
ASML自己說
它是今天全世界
唯一做得出這種機器的公司
機器裡還要搭配
土光組跟顯影的設備
這一塊
日本的東京威力科創
佔得很前面
2018年10月
韓國的三星宣佈
開始用極紫外光生產晶圓
2019年
臺積電的N7 Plus
製成也用上了極紫外光
進入大量生產
一臺荷蘭的機器
裝著德國的鏡子
配著日本的設備
放進臺灣跟韓國的工廠
同一段時間
曾經長期領先製程的Intel
卻卡住了
Intel跟臺積電不一樣
它主要是替自己製造晶片
它的10奈米制程
原本計劃在2016年前後量產
2018年它只能先少量出貨
到了2019年
才有比較大規模的產品上市
2020年7月
Intel又宣佈
下一代要再延後
良率比那一波的目標
落後了大約一年
這件事的影響有兩層
一層是Intel自己的產品
製程慢了
就比較難跟對手比
另一層是
他的對手
那些把製造交給
外面先進製程的公司
得到了追上來的機會
到了2026年初
Intel退出了
用自家18A
自己乘坐的處理器
他還在往前追
韓國的三星
也在做最先進的製程
於2022年
他比臺積電更早量產
下一代的電晶體結構
可是2024年
他的主管公開道歉
說公司讓外界擔心
他的技術競爭力
在先進的製程上
沒有誰一直站在最前面
想到這裡你可能一直在想一件事
三奈米一奈米到底是什麼東西的大小
答案可能跟你想的不一樣
它已經不是任何一個東西的大小了
早期的製程名稱
大致對得上電晶體上某個部分的長度
可是大約從20年前開始
名字跟實際的尺寸就分開了
AEEE Spectrum在2020年寫過
7奈米電晶體上大部分關鍵的尺寸
其實都比7奈米大得多
當時臺積電研究部門的副總裁黃漢森
2019年在一場演講裡說得更直接
今天這些數字就只是數字
就像車子的型號
像BMW5系列
或者Mazda6
所以e奈米
比較像一個世代的名字
意思是比上一代
同樣的面積
能放下更多開關
也更省電
臺積電的e奈米
已經在2025年
第四季開始量產
電競體的結構
又換了一次
從一片魚鰭
變成幾片疊起來的
奈米薄片
雜集從四面
把通道包住
開關又更容易關緊了
把一片先進晶片的來歷
攤開來看
你會發現
它從來不是一個地方
做得出來的
這種跨很多公司
很多國家的分工
叫供應鏈
大概可以分成三塊
頭一塊是設計跟軟體
設計晶片的公司
像NVIDIA
Apple
Qualcomm
很多在美國
設計晶片要用一種專門的軟體
叫EDA
中文叫電子設計自動化
這一塊
美國的公司也站得很前面
再來一塊是機器跟材料
荷蘭的曝光機
德國的鏡子
日本的材料跟設備
還有美國的其他機臺
最後一塊是製造
最先進的邏輯晶片
有很大一部分在臺灣製造
韓國站了很前面
把晶片包起來測試好
很多在亞洲其他地方完成
一片晶片
前前後後要經過幾百道
甚至上千道製程步驟
美國半導體產業協會寫過一個例子
單單一家美國的半導體公司
全世界的供應商就超過一萬六千家
一片晶片是一整條供應鏈一起做出來的
這條供應鏈平常看不見
直到有一天它卡住了
2020年
疫情讓全世界的人留在家裡
大家買電腦
買螢幕
買遊戲機
晶片的需求一下子往上衝
到了2021年缺晶片的問題
落到了一個很多人沒想到的地方
汽車
一臺現代的汽車裡有很多顆晶片
控制引擎
剎車
車窗
還有儀表板
它們很多不是最先進的晶片
可是隻要少一顆
整臺車就交不了
那一年
世界各地都有汽車工廠
因為等不到晶片而減產
顧問公司Alex Partners
在2021年9月預估
這一年全世界的汽車業
會因此少生產大約770萬輛車
很多人第一次感覺到晶片
不是在新聞上
而是在車行裡
業務員說你要的那臺車要等好幾個月
這件事讓大家看清楚一件事
晶片不只在手機跟電腦裡
它藏在生活的每個角落
而供應鏈只要一個地方卡住
影響就會傳到很遠的地方
晶片改變的
不只是我們手上的東西
也改變了科學家看世界的方式
我們身體的細胞裡
有一整套遺傳資訊叫Gnome
中文叫基因體
讀出一個人的基因體叫做定序
美國國家人類基因體研究所的資料顯示
2001年讀出一個人的基因體
大約要花9500萬美元
到了2022年只要幾百美元
這條成本曲線
從2008年前後開始
降得比莫爾定律還快
主要的原因是新一代的定序技術本身
可是新一代的定序儀
一次會吐出非常大量的原始資料
要把這些資料整理成一個人的基因體
靠的是電腦也就是晶片
醫生今天可以更快找出一些罕見疾病的原因
科學家可以比較成千上萬個人的基因
背後都是定序成本一路往下降
晶片沒有自己去讀基因
可是他讓讀出來的東西算得動
也存得下
2022年11月30日
ChatGPT上線
很多人第一次在一個數目框裡打字
機器用完整的句子回答
Microsoft說
他替OpenAI在ASUS上蓋了一臺超級電腦
用了好幾千顆NVIDIA的GPU
今天NVIDIA最新一代的Blackwell GPU
是兩片晶片接在一起
一共有2081個電晶體由臺積電製造
你還記得1971年那顆4004嗎
2300個
50多年
大約多了9000萬倍
可是訓練人工智慧
光有算得快的晶片還不夠
資料要能很快送進去
這就需要一種記憶體
叫HBM
中文叫高頻寬記憶體
他把好幾片記憶體晶片疊起來
中間用很細的垂直連線穿過去
這一塊
韓國的SK Hynix跟三星站在最前面
運算晶片跟記憶體
還要緊緊放在一起
臺積電有一種先進封裝
叫Sowars
他把運算晶片和一疊一疊的記憶體
並排放在同一塊錫底板上
用很密的線連起來
臺積電的執行長魏哲嘉
在2024年說過
產能很緊
今天限制人工智慧晶片產量的
不只是晶片本身
還有把它們接在一起的封裝
這條供應鏈
也開始受到國家政策的影響
2022年10月7日
美國商務部宣佈新的出口管制
限制先進的運算晶片
還有製造晶片的設備
出口到中國
出口管制就是政府規定
哪些東西賣到哪裡
需要先取得許可
2023年
荷蘭跟日本也陸續堆一些
一些晶片製造設備加上管制
2024年12月
美國在把高頻寬記憶體
也放進管制範圍
另一邊中國也在往前走
2023年
分析公司Tech Insights
打開一隻華為手機
發現裡面的處理器
是中國的中興國際
用7奈米等級的製程做的
而且沒有用極紫外光的機器
這些規則
這幾年一直在調整
有的收緊
有的放寬
每一條都有它的日期
我們在這裡不猜結果
只記下一件事
晶片從設計到製造
要經過很多的國家
所以每一條新的規則
都會讓供應鏈的某一段跟著調整
所以各國開始把工廠往自己家附近蓋
2022年8月
美國通過了晶片與科學法案
用補助吸引工廠到美國
臺積電在美國亞利桑那州的第一座工廠
從2024年底開始量產
Apple在2025年公開說
臺積電亞利桑那廠
正在替他生產好幾千萬顆晶片
日本熊本有臺積電合資的工廠
做的主要是比較神熟的這層
日本的新公司Rapidus
2025年在北海道做出了
奈米電晶體的試作品
目標是2027年量產
歐洲在2023年通過了自己的晶片法案
德國德勒斯登的新工廠
也在2024年動工
講到集中
有兩個數字常常被混在一起
一個是產能在哪裡
2021年一份美國產業報告
估計2019年全世界
10奈米以下的最先進產能
9成2在臺灣
其他在韓國
這描述的是當時集中的程度
另一個是公司的市場位置
市場研究機構Trendforce統計
2026年第二季
全世界晶圓代工的營收
臺積電佔了七成以上
這裡面也包括他在海外工廠的營收
蓋一座新工廠要好幾年
製造正在慢慢分散到更多地方
我們回到開場那個問題
一片這麼小的戲
是怎麼改變我們每天的生活
80年來
同一件事 一次又一次發生
真空管換成電晶體
收音機走進了口袋
零件跟連線一起坐在戲上
計算機放上了書桌 電腦
跟著太空人上了月球
線越做越細
個人電腦走進家裡
網路把他們連在一起
手機放進了每個人的口袋
今天同樣的晶片
讓機器開始回答我們的問題
所以這集的答案是
開關每變小一次
每偏移一次
就有一件新的東西
走進普通人的生活
可是要再往前一步
需要的人也越來越多
美國的設計
荷蘭的機器
德國的鏡子
日本的材料
韓國的記憶體
臺灣的工廠
還有中國 歐洲 東南亞
很多我們叫不出名字的供應商
這條供應鏈今天正在重新調整
工廠往更多地方蓋
規則也一直在變
對我們來說最實際的影響可能就是下一支手機
下一臺車
下一個人工智慧工具
會在什麼時候用什麼價錢來到我們手上
最後問你一個問題
在你的生活裡
是哪一樣電子產品讓你第一次覺得
日子真的被它改變了
留言告訴我
監視系列還會繼續
下一段歷史我們下一集再走
喜歡的話訂閱AI Notebook
開啟通知我們下次見